and you will never forget this
refutation and you should never forget
this reputation
you're a dejected individual a sick
person
so dawah are all the steps
that precede jihad in fact you should
and could see jihad
as an extension of doubt a mental
and ideological slave and i want you to
remember that
is the hijab 10 discount code for 10
discount on a wide range of products
including premium ethiopian black seed
products
today we're going to be dealing with an
intellectual fraud
an impostor a duplicious woman
an intellectual patron a slava degalian
yes a slava de gallen an individual who
has been caught
lying about their life experiences to
try
and manipulate facts thereby outcasting
and alienating and ostracizing
not only the muslim community which she
abandoned
but the somali community and the african
community
because she was caught lying
about her experiences saying that she
was there in somalia and there was a
civil war
when we know that she was in a
completely different country she was in
kenya
and she only fabricated those facts
in order to gain the sympathy of
individuals who she would thereafter
use in order to attack the muslim
community
foreign
what a scandalous woman she is what a
scandalous woman she is
but not only is that the case which will
not be the
subject of today's discussion
but she is an individual who if you
listen to her for more than five minutes
is a contradictory individual
not only in what she believes in or
espouses but in what she says in her
so-called intellectual engagements
let's take a look at some of these clips
that i found with a video in which
she was talking about dawah of all
things
she talks about
the first thing i found quite
interesting
was the fact that she says and this is
quite interesting
being a black african woman she
completely separates herself from
africa and from the so-called developing
world
and she says our listen to this our
western heroes referring to whom the
founding fathers
of america they're celebrating more than
we celebrate the founding fathers more
than we celebrate any of our
western heroes and then thereafter she
says
she's she attacks karl popper yeah and i
criticized popper for
for jumping for skipping muhammad
he goes from plato to hegel
and in between he forgets muhammad
and she feels that in many of her
publications
that the prophet muhammad was unethical
and so on
and yet she says our american
hero our western heroes referring to the
founding fathers of america
does she not know that the inception of
america
is almost no different at all from the
inception of isis
the pillaging and raping and genocide
of the native american population
does she not know being someone who
supposedly is against enslavement and so
on that so much of these founding
fathers
they possessed slaves themselves and
what
condemnation have we heard
from this intellectual
slave yes because i believe
if malcolm x was alive today that he'd
point at that individual
and he'd call her a house negro there's
no doubt about it
there's no doubt about it an individual
like that
who looks up to the savior of the united
states of america she says our american
heroes
we don't hear any criticism of a liberal
kind
of a moral kind
forwarded to those individuals
so why is it the case that you choose
to manipulate the facts as we will see
as this video progresses and matures
and try and smear not only just the
islamic
world or the muslim world but somalia as
a country
and africa as a continent
let me say something and then in the 10
years in medina that followed
the call the invitation the persuasion
the use of language
slowly transformed maybe not so slowly
transformed into the use of force she
starts talking about the dawah
and she says it slowly transformed to
the use of force
and obviously for those who know the
biography of the prophet muhammad
there was a 13-year period in mecca
where the muslims were being attacked
subjected to all kinds of torture all
kinds of boycott all these kinds of
things
which by the way evidences that this man
the prophet muhammad
was sincere to his cause since he was
getting no
so-called perks of them of this cause
for 13
entire years and he was offered a way
out many times but in these 13 years
and then there was a 10 year off period
after that called the medinan period
and she she in her language says slowly
move to the use of force
well if you look at chapter 22 verse
number 39 of the quran
it's very clear why that movement to the
so-called use of force
was implemented in the first place
that it has been given permission
expressed permission for those
believers who have been oppressed
to fight back so what she's trying to
portray
is this megalomaniacal attitude of the
muslim people
and this diabolical attitude and this
power hungry expansionist
attitude when in fact the the very
turning point in the seerah
is outlined in the very quran using
couched with language of justification
justification
because you have be in the home or
because they have been
volume oppressed but the language
here should be telling in the quran
the reason why and this is why the vast
majority
and an argument could be made for all of
the expeditions that took place in the
medinan period
were defensive the battle of bedrock the
battle of uh
it's not a it's an open secret all you
have to do is open a book of the
biography of the prophet muhammad
and you'll realize that these were
defensive expeditions that they were
and most of them were four on the
borders of medina
they had nothing to do with expansion
really
so dawa are all the steps
that precede jihad in fact you should
and could
see jihad as an extension of dawah
so this is a manipulative insertion
by this individual
this low-life individual who is trying
to use
islam and muslims and the developing
world so-called
developing world to create narratives of
hatred and animosity clash of
civilizations she uses this all the time
samuel p huntington's term so when
a non-muslim is invited to come to islam
and in and refuses
then force is justified you have stent
attention to the facts this is false the
quran clearly says
and there is consensus among the jurists
on this issue
there is no compulsion in religion that
truth
has been made clear from falsehood so
whoever wants to
believe in falsehood and believe in
truth then they will have the true
anchorage
the quran says in chapter 18
whoever wants to can believe and whoever
wants to can disbelieve
and yes these verses are
that the context is is talking about
disbelievers non-muslims
no there's nothing in the quran and
there is nothing in the sunnah
you liar that indicates that if
people do not become muslim that force
is thereby justified
you are a liar you are a liar
just as you lied about your life story
to try and bring yourself into the west
you lie about the quran and you sit
there on podiums
and manipulate the facts and you thought
you'd get away with it didn't you
and you thought you'd get away with it
didn't you the biggest challenge is the
extent to which agents of dawah listen
to what you say agents of dawa
meaning spreading islam the word tao
means really
inviting people to islam agents of that
so
people that try and invite people to
islam can exploit the constitutional
and legal protections that guarantee
american citizens
freedom of religion and freedom of
speech freedoms that would of course be
swept away
if the islamists achieved their goals
that's right
and this is actually part of a book
so-called book which is not even
referenced
and is is a nonsense book talking about
the muslim brotherhood and other such
things
and making it seem as if the muslim
brotherhood have some kind of handhold
on the
you know the western tower it's
absolutely false
people don't most people don't subscribe
to muslim brotherhood ideology if you
want to call it that
in the in the west our society then says
enough is enough and
up to here and not father we're going to
esta you know
we're going to enforce the rule of law
meaning what here
what is she actually trying to say she
is saying
the constitutional rights that they have
in america freedom of speech
freedom of expression freedom of a
religion
are being exploited by the dawah
carriers if you want to call them that
for the sake of argument
and that those individuals really have
to obey by the rule
of law and enough is enough inference
made that what you're saying is that
dower should not be
present and there should be laws against
it you are in
your own words an immigrant you've come
from
in 1992 you've come from another country
seeking refuge and now you're saying
enough is enough
who on earth do you think you are
who on earth do you think you are and
what do you think this is
this is fascism she in her in her entire
presentation there's nothing i
understood more than in her own
fascistic inclinations
and tendencies she's trying to disguise
it
but the truth of the truth this is it we
have to know the
the friend from the foe like carl
schmidt the famous political philosopher
representing fascism would say and that
by the way
you can have a fascistic liberalist you
can have that
fascism and liberalism are not two sides
of uh are not too completely
diametrically opposed things
they can actually work in tandem with
one another
it's possible so this is a kind of
fascistic presentation why don't you
just say that
that certain things should be off limits
for certain people
and that there are uh you know clear
boundaries as you want to put it so you
have a
fascistic presentation you're saying
this kind of uh
censorship should be allowed so you want
freedom of expression and freedom of a
speech
to apply to almost all other religions
and all other peoples but not to the
muslims into islam this is nothing but
a type of fascism and if you don't if
you want to refute that you can try and
refute that
but believe you me with your
pseudo-intellectual yeah
lacking of knowledge you won't be able
to refute much
and what i find really problematic
that is so sickening to the core to
listen to this woman speak
it's unfortunate that we now have a
democracy where
opposition you know healthy opposition
has become
obstruction so it's okay to criticize
islam
and that becomes obstruction but when
dawa is done which is islamic
propagation let's say for the sake of
argument
that you that that should be outlawed
and enough is enough
so hold on do you not see the
inconsistencies in what inconsistencies
and what you're saying
you're complaining you are literally
complaining at the fact
that any criticism against islam
according to your understanding
is seen as an obstruction becomes
you call it healthy opposition so when
criticism of islam is done
it's called healthy opposition and when
that is challenged it's called
obstruction
but when propagation of islam is done
which is a constitutional right
according to
u.s u.s constitutional law for example
that is somehow the obstruction
so all you're saying is let's treat
different people differently
you're not even making an argument from
violence you're not even saying this can
this is directly correlatable with
violence
and even if you did make that argument
it'll be a weak argument because
correlation doesn't always mean
causation
it's a fantasy so you have
no leg to stand on here you're
inconsistent
your inconsistencies are glaringly
obvious
how can you live with yourself having
such inconsistencies
this kind of cognitive dissonance how
can you live yourself with this kind of
intellectual cognitive dissonance
just 10 minutes before that you were
saying it's not healthy
obstruction and now you're saying it's
healthy abstract it's called obstruction
it's not healthy
opposition you're completely a
contradictory person
you make me sick you make me sick
what you are is a public intellectual
the man
he puts his hand on her hand and he says
you are a public
intellectual how patronizing how
condescending
you are republic until now you've got
the seal of approval
from the white man that you wanted to
get the seal of approval from
and then he says in another place he
says actually when she talks about her
immigrating from uh
so called from somalia but really from
kenya or wherever it was we don't know
in 1992 he goes you're doing fine let's
take a look at this
you know i came to the west in 1992 so
i'm a newcomer but you're doing fine
thank you so it's giving her his
approval you know
don't worry you're a public intellectual
even though you
you have uh you don't have the
qualifications for for that
or you haven't done peer-reviewed uh
stuff but you're a public intellectual
but look how condescending this is could
you imagine a white man like that
putting his hands on
uh jordan peterson and saying you're a
public intellectual
jordan peterson will look up at him and
say excuse me what the hell are you
doing
or any of the people that you know in
the west now who are pop academics
putting their hands up on richard
dawkins or any of these individuals and
saying
you're you are a a public intellectual
you say excuse me i don't need your
endorsement would you respect i don't
you know this is embarrassing
and you're smiling there sitting take
soaking it all up this is exactly what
you wanted isn't it
you wanted the white man your savior to
come and put his hand on yours
quite physically actually not just
intellectually because you have been
ideologically molested
you have been ideologically molested yes
but as i'm going to say you're public
intellectual oh
thank you oh thank you very much
is that is that the way you want to earn
respect in this world how embarrassed
you are you're a joke
you are an absolute joke
if the question is whether the west has
the courage to defend itself has the
will to defend itself
then you just identified the central
sub-question
within that question and that is
will the united states of america stop
ringing its hands
yeah what do you think
uh i hate to say it but something has to
happen to make us
focus and to stop bringing our hands
and looking at all of that i think it is
i don't know i feel a sense of urgency i
hope that you feel a sense of urgency
that we have something to defend
now this actually boiled my blood of the
many things that she said maybe this is
in the top three things that she said i
actually bought my blood
the west the united states of america
which went into a land which was not
theirs let's say
and completely destroyed the natives
built up and and went against many a
treaty
and then after that had i don't know 11
successive wars
in a span of i don't know how many years
how many people have they killed how
many
expeditions have they had vietnam north
korea
out iraq how many people have innocence
have died under the sorry the
superpower rain the short superpower
reign of the united states of america
and you have the audacity you and that
idiot are standing there sitting next to
you to say
when the west will defend itself you're
using the word defend
with a country that is the only or with
with the hemisphere the western
hemisphere
which is the only hemisphere responsible
for
a nuclear deployment of nuclear weapons
hiroshima and nagasaki are you talking
about that
defend itself are you sick in the mind
are you that mentally enslaved and
intellectually subservient
and intellectually molested and
ideologically molested
that you are actually talking about
defense for the biggest bullies
history has ever known
you really should be ashamed of yourself
but you should be humiliated
you should be humiliated you make me
absolutely sick and this is the reason
why
those people who hang around together
you
imagined nawaz sam harris and cole you
hang around together
but you'd never ben shapiro even i put
them in there as well
you guys would never you don't have the
fortitude
or the courage to stand forward against
the people that you're attacking
who are the muslim community get someone
from the muslim community and debate
them
you are a coward you are manipulating
the facts how can this man just be
sitting there
from the hoover institute and allowing
you to get away with so many blunders
and you will never forget this
refutation and you should never forget
this refutation
you're a dejected individual a sick
person
a mental and ideological slave
and i want you to remember that was
allah
you